a little bit of a game for you today
we're gonna play a movie version of
would you rather so picking between the
two options and then briefly explaining
why you would choose one or the other so
first would you rather work with a
director who gives you too many notes or
not enough really well I would rather at
this point in my life because I'm tired
more notes because I feel like they that
then it's like putting everything in
their hands and I can relax a little bit
how was it working with Bob in terms of
giving notes especially when you compare
the performance capture experience with
your live-action performance and he was
great he he the first time I met him it
was like the movie already existed in
his brain so and then I mean so it just
it was like just follow just you know
going along with his on this ride with
this man who is a genius and and it was
like such a great experience
would you rather screw up every single
take yourself or have somebody else
screw up your best take I probably the
first one I guess I don't know neither I
feel super guilty about everything so
I'd always rather take take that I guess
I guess that means I'd rather take the
blame and just suck it up right but then
what a waste if it's your best day it's
Jim neither would you rather have to do
a scene where you are running the entire
time or eating the entire time running
running I don't like eating because then
I get stomachaches and then and then I'm
like miserable and gassy I feel like
nobody really thinks about how much you
actually have to eat when you do one
scene 1 million times over
yes it's yes and if you're eating
something like hotdogs or you're just
ruined let's make it sound even more
unpleasant now another thing I feel like
not many people think about is would you
rather have to wake up in a scene or
fall asleep in a scene oh yeah um fall
asleep I feel like I'm bad really bad at
waking up and making it look real and
I'm really bad at driving in scenes I'm
really better I never look at the road
I'm always like sake I'm driving with
never look at the road I feel like I
would notice someone going like this on
the wheel more than not looking at the
road though like do both I do both I'm
like I've never caught it before so far
I'm saying it's wrap this up with a
little bit of a different note um Mark's
story here is so so specific but the
idea of finding emotional healing
through art is such a universal thing so
do you have any hobbies whether it's
artistic or something else that you go
to to center yourself acting um so thank
God I was able to find acting because
it's definitely been like a form of
therapy to me over the years and writing
in my journal that's a huge one um when
I do that every day I feel so much
better because I just get everything out
on in my journal hopefully nobody will
ever find those journals and read them
because it would be really bad
you